les candidats à la présidentielle
faisait leur grand oral face aux sapeurs
pompiers étaient également présents
christophe castaner qui rentrait de
boîte visiblement et le cadreur aussi la
question de la validation des acquis de
l'expérience par exemple pour les jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers implique une
mobilisation nous ne pouvons rien faire
rien agir pour sécuriser cette
organisation elle est éprouvée et elle
permet une meilleure coordination avec
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
intérieure comme dans l'action au
quotidienne est ce qu'on peut parler
hors antenne s'il vous plaît avec un des
collaborateurs
car
la personne avant d'écrire
[Musique]
à ce moment là on est on est assis à
table on est un peu mal à l'aise et
notre hôte nous nous nous présente deux
petits garçons
[Musique]
soient courageux au fait vous comptez
utiliser un ustensile en particulier
pour mettre toutes les filles d'accord
mon essentiel préféré c'est la mandoline
alors éteint car votre mandoline de
seconde main viennent rendre l'âme on
vous laisse le mot de la fin ce soir je
vais tout donner parce que je veux
sauver la planète si vous dites des
scientifiques ont pour projet de faire
renaître une race de rats leurs astuces
macler harry disparu depuis plus d'un
siècle oui oui l'étude est très sérieuse
on appelle ça la d extinction cette
espèce d'aura de l'île christmas en
australie pourrait donc bien être de
retour et pas pour repeupler nos égouts
déjà bondés mais pour démontrer une
véritable prouesse scientifique car si
cette expérience marche on pourrait
peut-être imaginer père et susciter
mahmoud dinosaures ou peut-être encore
le psg en ligue des champions bah ça
s'est très mal passé pour le psg hier
qui est finalement éliminé en huitièmes
de finale de la ligue des champions un
cauchemar pour les parisiens qui ont
mené 1 à 0 sur la pelouse de
santiago-bernabéu finalement à l'heure
de jeu karim
zemma signe un triplé ont seulement 17
minutes on a réécouté yannick noah et
son coup de gueule son craquage après
l'élimination du psg juste pour le
plaisir merci loana merci également à
jérôme bourgeois
j'en ai marre j'en ai marre du sticky
pourtant ce débat
j'en ai marre le fric de trucs
improbables
il arrive avec les deux gamins ils se
mettent autour des deux gamins c'est
énorme ils sont tous les coins pcc c'est
probable voilà la journée on compte
comme des dératés pour ne pas arriver
dernier est chopé un duel final elle
soit on se retrouve une soirée coupable
de kiki donc avec deux gros la paix de
gros truc qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc quoi on est on est quand même entré
d'halluciner quoi tu es perdu tard il a
des cheveux lamborghini rosich des
cymbales et je verrai il ya des trucs
intéressants que c'est mon cul tu es
perdu je sais même pas que cela j'ai de
l'ambition que tu voulais moi gueule
mais je regarde tatler physique moi je
t'ai bataclan fois sur ton chantôme est
dans les tons physique beagle
bienvenue dans mon univers les filles
j'adore c'est très vert donc moi le vert
ça me parle le recyclage ça me parle
évidemment je suis 100% en place sinon
voila je suis à fond dans le thème ah
oui grâce à vous la dépollution des
océans ne s'est jamais aussi bien portée
le centre de kiev se vide petit à petit
de ses habitants les rues sont de plus
en plus vides et puis tous les magasins
sont fermés
habituellement ici se brouillent de gens
aujourd'hui la ville de kef est
complètement vidée de ses habitants
impressionnant
elle est au front 104g donc en train de
me demander à ses collègues de faire
moins de bruit et de se pousser pour
qu'il puisse répondre aux questions de
ses followers
avec
500 1000 followers à la cua donc 500 me
non mais je pose la question ces cinq
cent mille débiles qui la suivent et
pourquoi pas
c'est débile
à 500000 débine qui les suivent tu
prends l'exemple d'un monde à dire tu me
prends l'exemple pas vraiment bien tu
mets ta mère mandat tu payes
mais pendant cette guerre les réseaux
sociaux jouent aussi un rôle d'exutoire
on y va pour décompresser et se marrer
en regardant des montages de poutine
chantant l'hymne ukrainien
si vous aimez
[Applaudissements]
ça donne
payez
brammo vers les trains bondés
perros qu'on est pas traiter des mots
ou des mots comme ça
bien sûr on a peur de menace nucléaire
on a tous peur qu'il appuie sur le
bouton moi je vous dis s'il appuie sur
le bouton rien ne les sortira tout est
rouillée où tous les fils son congé par
les rats
non mais ya rien de moins sûr non mais
là il faut qu'on avance parce que c'est
important de nous avons gelé ou profiter
un maximum de gonflants que le bateau
sont rouillés ya rien de moins sûr donc
hommage calmer là dessus que et je
préfère qu'ils n'essayent pas si vous et
moi c'est thibault
elle décrit sa vie dans un abri
antibombes les jours qui passent sans
pouvoir faire grand chose les rayons
vides des magasins mais elle le fait
avec les codes de tik tok
si elles sèment face c'est de la
mauvaise foi moi j'aime pas et c'est pas
de la mauvaise foi moi c'est du bon foie
gras le foie gras c'est une association
de viande
avariée quoi tu vois je pense qui s'est
alors
adressé des menaces et quand même
exceptionnel ce qu'elle vient de dire
soria en fait elle a mis tout son argent
dans les seins et donc mais rien dans la
cervelle quoi mais sans vous êtes
déchaînés le foie gras c'est ça c'est
comme la merguez la narguait c'est une
association de viande avariée foie gras
c'est la même chose
[Musique]
elle le fait aussi avec humour sur fond
de gros rap américain
j'ai pris 6 cl à la cie la ligne
éditoriale de l'émission de te prends
tous combien d'années tu me demander mon
avis oui mais chez lui quant à vie mais
si ça tourne en rond car elle lâché
garder mon âge et qui a tout donné sans
programme
c'est parti jean claude axe ils sont
partis ils sont venus ici or vu je sens
qu'il me ment et c'est vrai qu'avec le
drapeau rouge bien on découvre le vrai
visage des gens quoi s'y défend à
l'hypocrisie fois-là koh-lanta faupala
pékin express